there's another issue that's come up
recently we meant to get to this
yesterday but there were just too many
other things to address the question of
what the union wants going forward now
that we've all experienced
life in a pandemic and how
work has become more efficient from home
and things that used to be viewed as so
essential to making your business run
no longer
are quite as important and for the nfl
and specifically for the nfl players
association it's the otas the organized
team activities all those weeks of
workouts in the building
they've realized you know what it's
really not that critical to getting a
football team ready to go in september
and damora smith the nfl pa executive
director said earlier this week on a
conference call with reporters that and
i quote there's absolutely no reason for
us to go back to full-scale otas
now
part of the reality is
99
not quite 99 it's more like 95 or 93
percent of the off-season program is
voluntary but the reality is it's there
there's pressure on the players to be
there the coaches want them there
teammates want them there young players
see it's an opportunity to to curry
favor with the coaches and show what
they can do so the veteran players are
going to show up to protect their turf
if you just don't have them no one's
going to be there if you have them even
if they're voluntary you're going to
have most of your players present damore
smith's position is you don't need to
have these we don't need to have these
guys in the building they can have more
of an off season they can have more of a
life
like anything else though with
collective bargaining it's not going to
happen unless there's a give and take
unless there's a trade-off what do you
give up as the union to get the nfl to
give up these otas that we've seen for a
generation or longer now in the national
football league and i just can't help
but wonder whether that was some sort of
a signal to
the league hey if there's something you
want to be asking for this is kind of
what we would want in return we want no
otas we want fewer otas we want no
training camp experiences where we're
taken away from our families for a month
guys should be able to stay at home
training camps should be at the team
facility that's another thing that jc
treader the nfl pa president pointed out
the other day and i kind of like that
too again we're learning
that you don't have to show up and punch
a time clock to be productive that can
save the employer a ton of money because
you don't need to have the same physical
facilities where people show up for work
and it can make your employees more
productive the idea that people are
going to be distracted they're not going
to get their work done look you're
ultimately accountable for what you do
and if you're an athlete if you're not
in shape if you're not getting it done
then yeah you're not going to have a job
the only thing that reduced otas will do
to a football team professional football
team
it makes it harder for the younger
players to get the attention of the
coaches it benefits
the veteran players who otherwise would
have to worry about losing their job to
a guy who comes in and is there for all
of the otas and looks good and they
decide they can trust him and maybe they
give him some more responsibility going
into training camp and he performs well
they trust him some more and the next
thing you know
the veteran that was due to make six
million dollars is told well we only
want to pay you one million this year
and if you don't like it we're going to
cut you because we're comfortable with
this guy that we've studied over the
course of the last four months in all of
these off season workouts so that is one
change that would occur if it would come
to that um
and who knows again it it always is the
product of collective bargaining we
don't know what the union uh would want
in return or would want to give up or be
willing to give up if the nfl would say
let's go ahead and and reduce the ot
otas or otherwise make changes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports